i think doug ford's just playing a yo-yo
with his uh mandates there is a like a
little piece of bone
thrown in the front of the
very hungry pit board
and it's just not enough no we need we
need it on paper we need we need
we need the support from for the ford
government the trudeau government we
need it wrote on paper that
mandates are done
[Music]
so they eased it for
i don't know the general public to go to
a grocery store it doesn't the federal
government hasn't
hasn't changed their
point of view on it at all like
to me it was almost like nothing
one week it's this and then it's they
let you go and then they take it back
and they give it again
it's just like a yo-yo up and down we're
gonna we are waiting until all the
mountain mandates will be over
this is the only thing
after that we will leave but we need the
confirmation of our rights to be
reinstated
it would have been a lot better if they
could have got the federal thing done
they did drop restrictions but i think
they can take them back put them back on
whenever they want right
so we're not we're still not in a very
good place they've done
very little they've left it so
the next variant
whatever may happen next they right back
to
full power the issue is we know how
cheap and dirty games or government
playing now
i don't know what you can even believe
anymore that comes out of apartment
buildings
is a big problem right
as soon as they get the trucks out of
here they might just change their minds
and lock everything down again right
i have no idea what ontario's idea is i
think it's a step in the direction right
and direction um
that's what that's what we're here for
we're here to end all mandates and uh
get our freedom back
no it's drop it all of it done
it's not a big deal this covert is over
i already get uh a special delivery
today
like some sunscreen for august if i have
to be here
i don't want to get burned while i'm
sitting on my beach chair next to my
truck